[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur des dossiers sensibles
je vais vous partagez mon interprétation
tandis que le président turf erdogan
avec l'accord tacite des états unis
pratiquer la politique du fait accompli
et du rapport de force en méditerranée
orientale et que les émirats arabes unis
accompagné par bahreïn faisait la paix
avec israël une évolution majeure sur le
plan géopolitique s'est produite au
moyen-orient
le 23 juin le site iranien tabnak
relayée par la presse nationale a
annoncé puis publié un projet d'accord
stratégique entre l'iran et la chine
d'une durée de 25 ans alors selon armin
arefi du point ceci a fait réagir
violemment aussi bien les opposants
ultra conservateur regroupé autour de
l'ancien premier ministre mahmoud
ahmadinedjad que les nationalistes et
les libéraux vivant à l'étranger
le 16 juillet le ministre iranien des
affaires étrangères mohammad javad arif
qui fait partie du gouvernement modéré
d'hassan rohani a reconnu qu'il était en
phase finale de négociation et depuis
les deux camps dans de l'opposition
accusent le gouvernement de brader le
lion persan au dragon chinois dans ce
traité qui devra être validé par le
parlement et par le conseil des gardiens
de la constitution
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avaient ils un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en tous genres par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes ne les avons nous pas
pousser dans les bras d'un partenaire
qui ne souhaitait pas mais qui va en
profiter pour faire de l'iran sa tête de
pont au moyen orient
certes les relations entre les
etats-unis et l'iran ont toujours été
compliqué et on doit on rappeler
l'histoire pour comprendre comment nous
en sommes arrivés là
souvenez-vous en 1953 à la demande des
compagnies pétrolières américaines
la cia qui avait sur place comme
représentant on dire aujourd'hui chef de
poste
kermit roosevelt fils de l'ancien
président a renversé le premier ministre
mohammad mossadegh qui avait osé
nationalisé le pétrole
elle l'a remplacé par le shah reza
pahlavi qui a indiscutablement
moderniser le pays mais sous une manne
faire devant la montée des
mécontentements populaires
les etats-unis ont dû l'encourager en
1979 à s'exiler et a laissé la place un
gouvernement démocratique dont le
premier président fut monsieur banny
sabres il a été vite remplacé par
l'ayatollah khomeiny qui avait préparé
sa prise de pouvoir depuis la france où
il est exilé et suite à son arrivée les
manifestations anti occidentales de plus
en plus violentes ont abouti à la prise
de l'ambassade américaine
le 4 novembre 1979 et à la séquestration
de ces diplomates
ce qui fut une humiliation pour toute
l'amérique
après l'échec d'une tentative militaire
de récupération ils n'ont été libérés
par l'intermédiation de l'algérie que le
20 janvier 1981 par cette opposition
totale entre les états unis les iraniens
va complètement changer en 1985 avec la
sphère de l'irangate où l'on découvre
que les américains vendent des armes à
l'iran alors en guerre contre l'irak
soutenue par les français
rappelez-vous en les faisant transiter
par israël qui sert d'intermédiaire
il est donc clair que les ennemis
d'aujourd'hui
quoi qu'ils en disent ont collaboré en
d'autres temps
ce qui peut laisser un espoir de
solution d'ailleurs à l'époque
ceci permettait de penser que toutes les
progressivement entrer dans le rang mais
les mollahs iraniens chiites qui se sont
toujours opposés aux dirigeants sunnites
de l'arabie saoudite veulent avoir un
rôle international
il encourage et mouvements politiques
aux terroristes comme le hezbollah au
liban tout en éliminant leurs opposants
avec pour résultat un rejet de leur
régime théocratique par toute la
communauté internationale
avec la france la relation est encore
plus compliquée les iraniens aime la
france depuis toujours et à l'époque les
français avaient une sympathie marqué
pour le chat et surtout pour son épouse
la shahbanou farah diba qui avait fait
ses études en france
dans le même temps lyman commenee
réfugiés 1,9 le château faisait campagne
contre le régime
en utilisant des cassettes audio qu'il
faisait distribuer en iran
c'était un peu l'ancêtre un des réseaux
sociaux d'aujourd'hui alors que la
france attendait un minimum de
reconnaissance après la prise du pouvoir
de l'imam celui ci a lancé ses équipes
de tueurs sur le territoire français
pour assassiner les principaux opposants
régime des mollahs qui s'y étaient
réfugiés
souvenez-vous de bani sadr ou de chapour
bakhtiar de surcroît il n'a pas accepté
que la france continue à héberger un
mouvement communiste de résistance armée
qui s'était opposé aux chats et qui
s'opposaient maintenant à eux et
pratiquer le terrorisme
les moudjahidine du peuple dirigé
aujourd'hui par maryam radjavi
les relations ont continué à se dégrader
dans les années 80 compte tenu de
l'implication des deux parties au liban
souvenez-vous de la tacc du drakkar en
1983 à beyrouth qui tua 58 militaires
français et la suite d'attentats la
série d'attentât sur le territoire
national 1 qu'il y a eu à cette époque
en 1987 a éclaté l'affairé gordji durant
laquelle notre ministre de l'intérieur
charles pasqua a tenté sans succès des
changes et le diplomate iranien qui
était fortement suspecté d'être mêlé aux
attentats contre les otages français
détenus au liban après la fin de la
guerre iran irak en disant 88
la situation s'est doucement améliorée
mais l'iran se sentant cerné par les
grandes puissances régionales ayant la
bombe atomique comme la turquie via
l'otan
israël qu'il avait eue clandestinement
comme le pakistan et sachant que l'irak
aurait pu l'avoir décide de son dotée
également
alors à partir de l'an 2000
alerté par israël qui s'inquiètent
légitimement compte tenu des menaces des
leaders iraniens annonçant la future
destruction de l'état juif
les occidentaux voyaient d'empêcher
clients et réalise bombe atomique
israël va réaliser deux opérations
contre les savants et les installations
nucléaires iraniennes
le point d'orgue sera la cyber attaque
par le virus stuxnet des centrifugeuses
de lütschine de latence qui a détruit
semble-t-il à peu près 60% des fameuses
centrifugeuses indispensables à la
réalisation de la bombe et il ya de
forts soupçons pour que la sphère qui
s'est passé en france 2 chevaline soit
lié à ça puisque l'ingénieur qui a été
assassiné était un spécialiste du
nucléaire
parallèlement les sanctions économiques
internationales vont monter en puissance
et les échanges commerciaux se réduire
jusqu'au 14 juillet 2015 ou sera signé à
vienne entre les états unis la chine la
russie l'allemagne la france et le
royaume uni
en y ajoutant l'union européenne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil il
abandonne le militaire en contrepartie
le ministre américain john kerry avait
négocié une levée progressive des
sanctions économiques qui pénalise le
développement du pays que le mettre en
grave difficulté sociale comme le décrit
très bien l'article de gérard vespière
dans la tribune du 12 août
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens selon les contrôles de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
les américains ne vont pas lever les
sanctions
voulant détruire tout ce qu'a fait le
président obama comme le rappelle fort
justement renaud girard dans le figaro
du 21 juillet le président entre hommes
va décider unilatéralement le but
mais 2018 de rompre l'accord et
d'imposer son régime de sanctions
au niveau international il est vrai qu'à
cette époque l'iran chiite s'opposent en
syrie à la coalition occidentale en
soutenant bachar al-assad à travers le
hezbollah et ses passes dharan les
gardiens de la révolution contre
l'ennemi sunnite qui étaient représentés
par des châles qaïda
malgré les protestations des autres pays
signataires qu'il contraint à le suivre
le président entre hommes va même les
durcir en dépit de l'opposition des
fonctionnaires de son propre département
d'état et tout en encourageant les
actions clandestines informatique ou
technique contre les installations
iraniennes en liaison étroite avec les
israéliens auxquels il reconnaît le
droit de légitime défense
il est vrai comme le rappelle à mirko
louzy correspondant de la fp que son
ministre des affaires étrangères mike p
o
ancien directeur de la cia est un ami
personnel de yossi cohen patron du
mossad et que jared kushner que le
gendre du président trump est un ami
très proche du premier ministre benjamin
netanyahu durant la période récente
plus d'une vingtaine d'actions
clandestines de destruction d'objectifs
ou d'élimination deux responsables se
sont succédé
on peut rappeler pour mémoire
l'assassinât du très populaire général
souleymane sy considéré par beaucoup
comme le prochain président de l'iran
qui allait faire l'ouverture de son pays
vers le reste du monde ou encore le
nouveau sabotage de lusine de nathan ce
qui semble avoir retardé de deux ans la
réalisation du programme nucléaire
derrière ces actions
l'objectif déclaré est d'amener l'iran à
la faute pour pouvoir réagir beaucoup
plus fortement
comme l'expliquent antoine colonna dans
valeurs actuelles il faut obtenir le
casus belli qui affaiblirait la position
diplomatique iranienne voir justifierait
un bombardement massif de son potentiel
militaire
surtout il permettra aux états unis de
faire jouer le mécanisme du snav bac
auprès de tous les signataires de
l'accord de vienne pour obtenir un
retour automatique aux sanctions qu'ils
ne veulent pas alors pour nos auditeurs
permettez moi de préciser que le snack
bac est une clause contractuelle de
l'accord de vienne qui oblige tous les
signataires à revenir aux sanction
initiale
si l'iran ne remplit pas les conditions
de l'accord permet quand même de vous
rappeler que pour le moment c'est bel et
bien les etats-unis qui ont dénoncé
l'accord mais enfin oublions les
journalistes berman et sans coeur dans
le new york times du 10 juillet montre
que face à l'ampleur des actions
israélo-américaine les iraniens réplique
matériellement pour le moment avec
mesure si l'on regarde la réponse pour
souleymane sy a été un tir de missiles
sur un camp américain en irak qui était
à moitié vide et celle pour la
destruction d'un site de missiles et de
celui de latence semble avoir été une
tentative de cyber-attaques contre les
usines de traitement d'eau potable en
israël
alors pendant toute cette dernière
période les européens ont essayé de
maintenir un minimum des changes avec
l'iran mais l'embargo et sanctions
américaines ont fait fermer peugeot qui
était la première entreprise automobile
du pays empêché total de développer
l'énorme gisement gazier de south pars
sans phase du qatar et nos industriels
de commercer avec ce marché des
allemands qui ont toujours eu des
activités économiques avec l'iran et qui
ont maintenu des liens politiques
pendant toute la durée de tous ces
événements les allemands donc en
contournant les règles de l'embargo sur
l'utilisation du dollar et des circuits
financiers américains via de petites
banques provinciale indépendante reste
un des très rares pays ayant une
continuité dans les relations et un
minimum d échanges commerciaux totaux un
sujet de la tentative de déployer les
systèmes allemands en europe qui
intéressait évidemment la france n'a pas
abouti par suite de l'opposition
d'autres pays qui n'y étaient pas
favorables
le projet d'accord sinon iranien prévoit
sur 25 ans 400 milliards de dollars
d'investissements dont 280 sur
l'industrie pétrolière et gazière
ce qui va permettre la mise en
exploitation du gisement de south park
est sans doute de mettre en place et
oléoducs et gazoducs permettant
d'approvisionner directement la chine
sans passer par la voie maritime 120
milliards seront consacrés aux
infrastructures des zones de
libre-échange permettront de renforcer
la route de la soie et la chine fournira
les équipements numériques dont la
fameuse 5 g
sur le plan militaire les iraniens vont
bénéficier de l'assistance chinoise au
motif qu'il négocie actuellement l'achat
de matériels sophistiqués comme les
missiles sol-air s-400 aux russes ils
donneront en contrepartie des facilités
pour les avions et navires militaires
chinois qui vont avoir accès à des zones
nouvelles comme la mer caspienne et le
golfe persique
enfin ils vont se faire aider en
cyberdéfense face à tous ceux qui les
attaquent et en particulier leurs
voisins
certes il y à des contreparties car les
chinois comme les russes n'ont pas
l'habitude de faire des cadeaux
le pays devra régler ses dettes sous une
forme ou sous une autre
mais il sera difficile de revenir en
arrière une fois que l'accord aura été
mis en avant pour la chine c'est une
très belle opportunité au moment les
américains se désengage du moyen orient
et sont affaiblis par leurs problèmes
internes le président xi jinping va
pouvoir profiter des facilités
militaires portuaire et aériennes
conforter une des nouvelles routes de la
soie garantir une partie de ses
approvisionnements en pétrole et en gaz
à un prix réduit 30 % d'après les
estimations et augmenter sensiblement le
niveau des échanges économiques
de plus l'utilisation du yuan au lieu du
dollar pour une partie des échanges va
permettre de contourner les sanctions
américaines centraux pyrite et les états
unis car les chinois qui sont comme vous
le savez des commerçants dans l'âme ne
veulent pas abandonner le marché
américain
en dépit des tensions actuelles on l'a
vu d'ailleurs récemment quand ils ont
réduit leurs achats en iran pour le
remplacer par du gaz et du pétrole de
schiste américains pourtant payer plus
cher
bien entendu aux états unis les
démocrates considèrent que la politique
des sanctions est un échec car elle à
pousser l'iran dans les bras des chinois
et des russes tandis que les
collaborateurs républicains du président
trump il trouve une justification de
leur politique en constatant que le
rapprochement avec la chine est bien la
preuve qu'on ne pouvait pas leur faire
confiance
une chose est certaine la mise en oeuvre
de sanctions américaines durci ont mis
l'iran en grave difficulté au plan
économique et social
et ceci s'est considérablement aggravée
avec la crise du coc vide aujourd'hui ce
pays doit rapidement trouver une
solution pour s'en sortir
pour l'ambassadeur de france bertrand
besancenot dans la lettre de est celle
du 31 juillet l'iran après avoir essayé
vainement de se rapprocher des
occidentaux veut montrer qu'il existe
une autre voie de développement et de
partenariat
sans eux après avoir fait chuter le
projet d'accord à quatre mois des
présidentielles aux états unis ce qui
est sans nul doute un message très fort
indiquant qu'en cas d'absence de
changement notable de la politique
américaine à leur égard ils en tireront
les conséquences
il ouvre ainsi la porte à un marchandage
avec washington sur la base un
assouplissement du niveau des sanctions
notez que le président trump apprenant
le projet a rappelé qu'il était prêt à
négocier sans en préciser les conditions
la signature de l'accord va donc
dépendre de l'élection américaine
bien qu actrice de l'accord sur le
nucléaire on peut craindre que l'union
européenne se retrouvent marginalisés ou
absente dans ces négociations
son incapacité à concevoir une stratégie
géopolitique et géoéconomique
indépendante et globale au niveau du
marché que le représente lui permet
malheureusement pas d'être une
alternative crédible dans cette
évolution qui va changer les équilibres
au moyen-orient
c'est d'autant plus regrettable que la
france comme on l'a vu avec
l'intervention du président macro liban
ou de celle de son prédécesseur en syrie
considère l qu'il y a des intérêts
historiques politiques et économiques à
défendre dans tous les cas de figure le
futur stratégique de l'iran qui fut le
coeur de l'empiré persan en étant
positionné entre le moyen-orient et
l'asie centrale sera impacté par son
choix et les avantages obtenus
d'un côté ou de l'autre cela aura des
conséquences sur tout le moyen-orient
mais également sur l'europe qui risque
d'avoir à sa porte
une implantation chinoises majeures dans
un pays à fort potentiel de
développement
à bientôt
[Musique]